even though I'm in this situation now
um it was something I always wanted to
do and I'm proud of what I did was there
any damn thing I was good at
um so yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't change
it for the world
do you ever miss the military oh
massively
massively without a doubt the resigning
nods there yeah oh I've got no purpose
the purpose I say it to my wife every
day I ring it every day I've got no I've
got no purpose
what's my purpose during the arm when I
was 16.
you know the 23 freaking years
and you introduced that's what happens
you become that person and then you
leave the Army you've lost civilians
don't understand the banter they don't
understand what you go through they
don't understand your PTSD they don't
understand war or anything and you just
feel you've got no purpose
you know you end up isolating yourself
I've got no uh I know Toby's in contact
with friends and family Marines and all
that me no one no one 23 years I mean
I've got no comms with no one except my
number one and I saw my number two that
I used to sniper with
because we were close because you had to
be close as a sniper pair you know but
yeah that's really sad great yeah yeah
and that's how I feel and I I it's
yeah I can understand that because in
Australia
showing the Afghan and
Iraq War
I think only 40 Australians were killed
but since the war 500 British Australian
soldiers have committed suicide
it's unbelievable isn't it
I do think having
a network of your friends that you did
so with certainly has got me through my
hard times in the last two years and
sure Toby will agree so you know maybe
time might change you might feel like
you want to connect with those but
equally I can see why people don't it's
sort of a way of just moving on to the
next chapter when I got diagnosed with
cptsd my regimen just disowned me
disowned me they put you in that wounded
soldier unit where you get an officer
attached to you I wasn't allowed back in
Camp or no one rang me from the family's
office ncos or nothing friends I thought
were friends no one rang me [__] you I'm
not waiting for that I'd rather be on my
own
that's a huge feeling on airports
especially considering when you've given
to the Army I think it's really a huge
feeling massive I think what I miss as
well is that you know we all wear a rank
in our name certainly on our flying suit
we have you know I was you know flight
Sergeant McConaughey crewman and I
wonder if that was to other people knew
who I was or if I so I knew who I was
because I could look at that every day
and go that's who I am it's a bit like
you could look at it and go Sergeant
Craig whatever and you you know who you
are by looking at that badge and when
you're stripped of that badge and
stripped of the uniform which
essentially becomes your identity you
know whenever I put my flying set on it
was like my Wonder Woman costume I was
that person and you it's not that you
felt you were Invincible but you felt
like you're a part of something you were
all there wearing the same uniform all
there as a big team and suddenly I was
just Liz from beers and Stoke walking
around Tesco's and I wasn't important to
anyone at all I get looked after from
my Squadron and my unit very well
and I feel terribly
upset Craig by what you've said that's
really like punched me right in the gut
um to the point where yeah I mean after
this I'm gonna go and
yeah I have a word with somebody because
that's bang hard of order yeah
and I'll tell you some more stuff off
camera as well it's the supporting me I
suspect you're not the only one who
that's what I've been finding sad is
that this is just your story and there's
probably about another you know 30 or 40
if not hundreds of people like you and
that's quite sad really and some you
know they need to do something about
that
especially considering what you give
if you if you could do it all over again
would you still join the military
oh yeah I'll join the Marines
that's what I would do hell yeah yeah
that's what I would have done yeah even
though I'm in the situation now
um it was something I always wanted to
do and I'm proud of what I did
um yeah it was the only damn thing I was
good at so yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
change it for the world yeah well I join
if I thought it's worth fighting for
it was defending my country
or my belief
that's that's my opinion anyway I think
I would anyway I don't know 100 years
old I'm a bit too old to join up again I
think I was you know absolutely
supporter of the queen loved the queen
but I don't think I ever you know went
to Afghanistan to serve Queen and
Country I went because I you know I
wanted to go with my mates I didn't want
to not go through one of them would go
and catch up a bullet that was meant for
me and it's been part of that team and
from a lot of the guys I've spoken to
you kind of went the guy left and right
of you to go with them you didn't
necessarily you know put on your uniform
and head off to foreign soils for Queen
and Country it wasn't really about that
yes we all swore on Earth to the queen
but it was more about your mates and
your Band of Brothers that you went to
fight for I don't know if that's right
but
yeah certainly the vibe I got from most
people yeah yeah I was shot
um and on a previous operation I was
shot in the arm
um through the shoulder and
after my time at
um you know the hospital at Bastion I
was I was given the opportunity to
either go back home for some r r and and
so on and so forth or I could stay out
in the theater because it wasn't that
severe
um
and I chose to stay out because of
exactly what you're talking about Liz I
didn't want some someone else coming out
and then thinking oh yeah I get to go
back and um
you know spend time in the UK and
someone else was out yeah who
potentially could catch it up
[Music]
so I was I was determined like
determined to stay out even though
everyone was telling me narutobes you
know you need to go back and get your
head straight and so on and so forth and
sort yourself out but no I decided to
stay and um
yeah to no yeah a couple of weeks later
or whatever it was
um yeah I ended up getting shot in the
neck and paralyzed for life but
yeah I'd rather me than than somebody
else you know
or to live with that guilt that oh yeah
I went home and someone else came out
and is now in this position because I I
took the option or
for me the easy way out
yeah
foreign
have you ever killed someone and how did
that feel
the tough one
um
me personally as a sniper yes I have